c'est même
quasiment
gelé jolie étudiante en 2006 il a été
voir gribouille qui doit l'aider à finir
son dessin de fleurs une pensée propre
aux bravo il ne te promis de ne pas
quitter le genre de nous devions faire
un jurançon
alors il a dû oublier parce qu'il n'en a
pas parlé suite à dire mais qu'est ce
que je vais trouver voix pour distraire
les enfants maintenant
[Musique]
c'est la pleine forme
pour sûr je ne sais pas ce qui s'est
passé mais aujourd'hui il y avait moins
de courrier que d'habitude c'est
pourquoi j'ai déjà terne je me sens
presque en vacances s'attaque à fait
clair ça fait plaisir de vous voir aussi
gai à eau à propos de gaieté avez vous
vu casimir j'espère bien qu'il ne va pas
tarder bon alors je peux l'attend ouais
comme j'ai tout mon temps je peux 1
c'est indiscutable facteurs facteurs il
me semble que vous avez une petite idée
derrière la tête en bas pour tout vous
dire en soit j'ai rencontré monsieur 10
nov qui m'a parlé de la nouvelle chanson
de casimir sur les enfants alors j'ai je
veux demander à casimir de me lâchant
roubaix c'est une très bonne idée
facteurs je meurs dans vie de l'entendre
une seconde fois ils savent à remplacer
très avantageusement au jeu
[Musique]
voilà mais voilà
j'ai terminé mon destin il ne reste plus
tard à colorier je suis formé spa
facture
très fort mais qui à ses dires il ya un
autre domaine où tu est également très
fort mais attention je suis fort dans
tous les domaines
peut-être en modiste parce que je suis
vraiment très très mauvaises pour la
question n'est pas là casimir nous
aimerions que tu nous chante la nouvelle
chanson est bien la question et qu'il
n'en est pas question qu un
nom aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de dessiner
un point c'est tout
ça
pour sûr je suis déçu attend d'être et
nous allons réfléchir nous allons
certainement trouver une solution
ça y est c'est fini
on sur mademoiselle julie l'idée de
françois est excellent grand concours de
chant son premier prix avec nos vies
ville via la formidable il ne reste plus
qu'à elle et l'accroché lac près de lui
ne bougez pas je m'en charge
approchons
au françois avez vous remarqué cette
pancarte là non ça alors je n'en reviens
pas gros concours de chansons 1er prix 1
mais pour sûr ça n'a rien de drôle
maintenant je lui ai pas vu mon pc 1er
prix
globi boulga à toulouse et tout en même
temps qu'à grandir enfin vous ne voyez
pas que je suis très occupé signe de
victoire il y à un grand concours avec
comme premier prix un gloubi boulga
alors avec le magnifique dessin quand je
viens de faire je suis sûr de gagner
mais non ça n'est pas un concours de
dessins et nous c'est un concours de
chansons avant alors ça ne m'intéresse
pas premier créé un gloubi boulga
oui j'ai entendu mais je n'ai pas faim
alors s'il vous plaît laissez-moi
dessinée c'est raté
pour sûr je crois que nous n'entendrons
pas la chanson aujourd'hui il ne faut
pas nous décourager il ya certainement
une idée à trouver
alors françois avez vous trouvé une idée
non pas une mais ça y est j'ai une idée
les enfants
que leur dites m j'en sais rien docteur
tessinois se passe-t-il quand soit plus
en plus jamais ma quand on avait des
soins de demain je me dis ça me paraît
je vais même beaucoup et le contraire
écoutez
[Musique]
quand j'ai voulu saluer les lapins du
terrier d'à côté
j'ai mis ma tête dans l'eure mais coincé
jusqu'au
j'ai tout fait
malheureusement les enfants
favidema temps
ils m'ont tiré très fort par les pieds
et j'ai pu respirer
tout en haut d'un mur de pierres ap
quand les arts verts je dansais
quand il a dit on descend j'ai senti
tout mon sang se glace et
heureusement les enfants
un
temps
ils ont tendu une couverture j'ai pu
santé du mur
[Musique]
l'offre dans l'île aux enfants je chante
joliment mes chansons
si j'ai la voix qui déraille
mémoire qui défaille
attention
[Musique]
enfants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on n'a pas dit mot
le quasi
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui mais
[Musique]
et
ouais et alors
[Musique]